the five number summary is an ideally be
looking at over the last week and a bit
it consists of these five different
pieces that go in to try and summarize
data five points I wonder if you could
remember them in order any takers what
the [ __ ] was what the first alone it's
the minimum it's the lowest score you
can see in the entire data set okay so
what's the minimum then we go sort of
question towards the middle what do we
encounter as we climb up we hit that
model for time which is indicated by q1
I'm actually going to write the lower
quartile you can record with the
Dennises you see this q1 is often
written as ql l standing for hello ah
okay good after q1 in what are you get
the median which we also sometimes
called g2 so we are the median is what
is significant about the median yeah
this is a very little number fantastic
so you've got the middle number which
divides the scores into a bottom half
and a top half or a less than a right
just like the median strip down on a
road you've got the median q1 q2 q3
surprise surprise and this of course it
does how important is the upper quartile
oops there we go now you've got your
quarter there before we get to that last
nut bar there's a particular name to the
distance or the gap between the lower
quartile and the upper quartile they
don't remember what that name is called
very good the interquartile range is
exactly what it sounds like it's the
range the difference between the
quartiles heads its core time last piece
of summation maximum fantastic so you
got the minimum and the bags and just
what you could get to quartile range
here you've got the regular made from
the top to the bottom
okay that's the whole distance what
she's going to these five numbers that
you really knowledge to get it over
all the pieces of stem school but it's
like five doubles it's a bit of a
headache to training look at each of
planetary workouts going on to drive
each other and we call that visual
representation in the picture a boxplot
or above as less you a box-and-whisker
plot so let's remember how do we draw
one of these things well here's a set of
data the first thing you've got to do in
order to get to a box plot or a bunch of
whisker plot you you need to do these
five numbers okay some of the bits are
easier to see and from there are harder
for example min another maximum you can
set them forward write down what I
inspiring already there's a bit of a
three right there and breathe and 15 is
the max so you don't have to go very far
to get birth to but when you get to q1
q2 q3 your quartiles you suddenly need
diet are cats in order this is just a
random mess okay so it can't give you
about 30 seconds go ahead can you put
this data in 34th can you place them
into ascending order
go ahead and do that to me so here's
what we've got on by the way some of you
actually just saw us now I was making
sure then I got all of them I saw there
were 13 scores Pierce I've got to get 13
14 and I notice I only had 12 so that's
why I'm you a mid one so watch after
that one of these you can do to help you
is maybe you want to cross off scores in
case you want to make sure you'd
absolutely miss any but I'm one of us so
you can still read it so now I have my
dinner and my back there are an odd
number of scores so that means the
median is going to be one of these
scores which one the middle one which is
the middle one so you'll be the seventh
score out of the team so if you have a
look you can up one two three four five
six seven
interesting leaders have a glorious
seven so there's my median
then we're going to stay okay I want
four times I won four times how do I do
that
beautiful cruising okay so I wanted a
little slip what I've got there into
four sections this one into two and this
one Institute so have a look over here
what's the bill three four five five do
I care at the seven you know the one
that was the median for why not
not hardly for that okay because it was
one of the actual data points for my
quartiles right I now take it out of the
one
so therefore Q 1 is going to be between
it'll be far enough and you can make the
opposite sort of illustration of it here
is it here is the upper quartile q3 and
it's going to be nine right so now I
know what my five numbers will be it or
not it's going to be three four and a
half seven nine and then okay what
Murphy before we actually start to
construct this there were thirteen
scores and you can count up from the
middle work out what's going order you
can tell Centauri in 13 the smaller
number what if I gave you like you know
63 schools or something like that and it
was all actually it or not so you do
need to reorder them 63 sourcing way too
much going on how can it quickly work
out which one is the middle school do
that so I know it's going to have to be
something to do with harbin right
because I'm trying to get half on this
side and half on that side when you have
63 you can tell me what do I get 131 or
and a half okay but we know this is an
odd number of schoolers so actually what
not between two school I want a
particular school which one is it
so you always round up if you have
trouble remembering that that's the case
okay think very [ __ ] simple example
think if you had five scores
right you can immediately see which
one's the bean you okay but if you try
this approach or what happens five
scores you Harbor what that big 12.5 and
you know you're gonna have to round up
to get to the third one does that make
sense so this is useful this person is
useful because it saves you from having
to count both images basically half
dinner time tips okay now we're ready
right so when you're working out water
if you do please provide available with
you they're doing burning good question
I want to avoid I would avoid doing this
again sorry I would avoid doing it from
the beginning because you don't go from
the out there am I going to include this
median or not okay because from the
beginning it's a question of whether
this is divisible by four or not so what
I would advise you do is find the
meaning in the way that is just
described and then think about it from
video so now I've got six scores six
scores so it's going to be between the
third fourth and sixth ones over there I
get a wee bit super furnivall if I went
for this right you want the event this
way you've got 30 second score is the
medium so there's a 30 second score yep
how many schools will be on the
Letterman there are be 91 scores over
here and there will be another 31 over
here right so now I think through this
process of these I'd you divide by 2
that gives you the number it gives you
is 15 and 1/2 and you note about up to
that it says that again yeah so from
there you'd say therefore the 16th score
and over here just be careful
this is the 60s tour starting from 1 but
now with the 16th score over here how do
I do that
the same way it's just on the account
that way cause in this way
do you agree because it should be
symmetrical yeah so you can count up
sixteen that you can count down six then
you'll get to save save it